-You prepared
for State of the Unions
when you were working with
the Bush presidency.
-Yeah.
-How do you think
they're preparing for Tuesday,
and how do you feel about --
It seems like people
are looking back
at the Bush State of the Unions
in a different way now.
[ Laughter ]
-Look, we -- we --
We didn't usually have
high expectations --
You know, he was -- Bush --
I loved Bush.
[ Laughter ]
He wasn't known --
He wasn't known for these, like,
soaring rhetorical skills.
-Right.
-But his speeches
were thoughtful,
and he would consult
with his own party,
and he'd try to have policies,
and there were bipartisan things
that we knew both parties
would support.
This White House
is a little more
fly by the seat
of their pants,
and they have a guy named
Stephen Miller,
who you've talked about.
-Yeah.
-You cover Stephen Miller.
-Who isn't really known
for doing anything
that unites anybody.
The unique thing
about this speech
is that they are on their heels.
They are on their knees.
They're in such a position
of weakness.
He's going to have
to do something
to sort of shake up
his own political standing.
-Isn't it terrifying?
And I know this happens
all the time.
Is there nothing more --
or I would say --
I feel like the most terrifying
thing in the world
is, like, Donald Trump needing
to do something to shake it up.
-Yeah. Please.
-Please, yeah.
-Like, just somebody
going in like,
"We've got to change the game."
You're like, "No, I don't --"
-No, please don't.
-Yeah.
Just, like, maybe like go back
and read the rules of the game.
-Right. [ Laughs ]
-Just to, like, see, like,
what's normal.
-Right.
[ Applause ]
-Have Pence do it.
-Pence do it.
I can't im--
I feel like he's going to do
the whole State of the Union,
like, looking back at Pelosi.
-Right, right.
-The fact that she's
over his shoulder.
-Yeah.
-I mean, she can --
-That relationship
is so interesting.
I mean, she --
she became Speaker
while my old boss
was still president.
And so I've been to this movie,
I know how it ends --
well for her, not well for
the Republican president.
And the fact that no one
studied sort of her --
not just her
legislative acumen,
but she can do what
really no one else
in either party can do --
she can hold her party
together.
And I don't know if it's all
of her experience.
I don't know if they
fear/respect her.
It's usually a combination of
that in politics, at least.
But she can hold
her party together
the way no other
Democrat or Republican can.
-Well, I think in that way
that there are --
I think there are Republicans
who thank God right now
that there is
Mitch McConnell,
because Mitch McConnell
gets things done.
I mean, if you're a Republican
right now --
-Or keeps them
from getting done.
-Yes.
-Can we boo? Can we boo?
-You can do whatever you
want, you're my guest.
-All right, he said
Mitch McConnell! Boo!
-All right...
[ Booing ]
-Okay, all right, sorry.
-But I mean, like,
it seems like Nancy Pelosi
is his -- you know, that, like,
you ultimately need somebody
who understands how it works.
And it seems to me that
Nancy Pelosi and Mitch McConnell
understand how things work.
-Definitely.
-Whereas when you have
somebody like --
Donald Trump does not
fundamentally understand
how it works, and anything
he's getting accomplished
is through the help of somebody
like Mitch McConnell.
-Yeah, everything.
And everything
that he fails to do,
it comes from --
is born from that incompetence.
And if it isn't covered
on "Fox & Friends,"
he hasn't learned it yet,
two years in.
-Yeah.
-I mean, that is his whole
sort of going to school.
And to their credit,
this week, they finally said,
"Whoa, you are not --" I think
they said, "You are not a king."
I mean, he's even
getting pushback
from his trusted sources
of information.
-There's a lot of talk about
how the media is going to cover
the 2020 election, and how --
you know, the danger
of talking about it
like horse race politics
and whatnot.
But isn't the person
that's most likely
to be distracted by
the 2020 election
the president himself?
-Of course.
And it won't even be the
substantive attacks on his --
sort of the cruelty
and vapidness
of his policy and his tweets.
It will be the person
with the biggest crowds.
So Kamala should be the person
that Democrats are most
excited about.
She has the thing
that scares him the most,
the biggest crowd.
-And he's probably just
sitting there trying to come up
with a nickname for her
right now.
-I mean, you --
definitely.
And if you go back to the first
day of his presidency
where he sent his
press secretary out to lie,
he went to the CIA
and sort of debased the CIA
by bragging about
his crowd size.
She now had the thing that we
all know he values the most,
the biggest crowd.
-Yeah.
Well, it's certainly going to be
interesting to watch.
We'll be happy to watch you
talk about it.
Thank you so much for being
here. It's always a pleasure.
Thank you as well, Rosie.
-My pleasure.